[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos del impacto social que ha
tenido de la escalada de tensiones entre
israel y palestina y que ya ha causado
cientos de muertos y miles de heridos el
lado palestino ha sido el que más ha
sufrido estos ataques para ello saludo
en este momento a raquel martí ella es
directora ejecutiva de la agencia de
naciones unidas para los refugiados
palestinos raquel gracias por su tiempo
y por estar con nosotros en france 24
cuál ha sido el impacto que ha tenido en
la población palestina esta nueva
escalada de tensiones cómo se compara
con la violencia vivida en la ofensiva
del 2014
sí hola muchísimas gracias por este
espacio dedicado a los refugiados de
palestina pues la situación es realmente
preocupante puesto que israel están
bombardeando de forma intensiva zonas
residenciales y estos bombardeos también
están afectando a numerosas
infraestructuras civiles como son
escuelas clínicas también redes de agua
potable e incluso parte de la central
eléctrica de gaza estos bombardeos
además se están llevando en mayor
intensidad por las noches cuando las
familias están en sus hogares y tenemos
constancia de que de nuevo al igual que
en el 2014 están desapareciendo familias
enteras bajo los escombros de las casas
cuando son bombardeadas tenemos además
el problema añadido y no hay que olvidar
que estamos en plena pandemia
hoy se reportaban mil casos nuevos de
covite en la zanja de gaza
tenemos que prácticamente el 53 por
ciento de las camas están cubiertas por
pacientes de kobe y que las unidades de
cuidados intensivos están cubiertas al
57% por personas con kobe esto da mucho
en muy poco margen e influye todavía más
en los miles de heridos que estamos
recibiendo en las clínicas y los
hospitales hasta la fecha llevamos 1300
más de 1300 heridos algunos con unos
estados muy graves por otro lado en las
fronteras están cerradas
egipto únicamente está permitiendo la
evacuación de algunos heridos para ser
tratados en egipto pero los pasos
fronterizos con israel están cerrados no
se está permitiendo la entrada de ayuda
humanitaria que en este momento lo
necesitamos muchísimo
ustedes estaban diciendo que se están
bombardeando con mucha intensidad son
las residenciales e incluso lugares
donde hay escuelas precisamente le
quería preguntar por las escuelas de la
agencia que están funcionando como
refugios para los palestinos desplazados
dentro de la franja como logran atender
a estas personas en medio de la crisis
en la situación actual que estamos
viviendo y con la intensidad de los
ataques aéreos prácticamente no estamos
pudiendo prestar los servicios
necesarios a la población que está
llegando a nuestras escuelas a
refugiarse lo único que estamos pudiendo
hacer es abrir estas escuelas para que
la población que ha perdido sus hogares
o que está siendo desplazada por los
fuertes bombardeos puedan buscar refugio
a nuestras escuelas pero como digo la
densidad de lo que estamos viendo que no
tiene precedentes con anterioridad no
nos permite hasta ahora llevarles
alimentos llevarles agua y ni siquiera
nos está permitiendo establecer las
medidas de seguridad de kobe porque
evidentemente el el hacinamiento que van
a crear en estas escuelas va a ser muy
difícil poder contener la transmisión de
lakovic en estas circunstancias y además
que no se compadece con lo que sucedió
en el en el año 2014
recordemos que en ese año ya fueron
bombardeados las escuelas de la onu y
que fue una tragedia terrible para la
humanidad ahora estamos a las puertas de
que algo así vuelva a suceder el primer
ministro de israel benjamin netanyahu lo
que dijo fue que iba a ir
edificar y continuar con los bombardeos
entonces realmente tienen ustedes
garantías como organización para
proteger la vida de las personas
no tenemos ninguna garantía porque en el
pasado no solamente en el 2014 también
con anterioridad nuestras escuelas
fueron bombardeadas escuelas en las que
había población civil refugiada tanto
mayoritariamente en niños y mujeres de
hecho en el 2014 hasta en cinco
ocasiones se bombardearon estas escuelas
y murieron muchísimas de estas personas
refugiadas y centenares resultaron
heridas son escuelas que están
señalizadas con la bandera de naciones
unidas que nuestros tejados están
señalizados con las siglas de naciones
unidas y que además de estos reforzamos
con el ejército israelí la posición de
estas escuelas para que no haya ocasión
y a pesar de ello nuestras escuelas
fueron bombardeadas esta mañana
recibíamos a través de la fuente fuentes
locales la noticia de que se estaban
evacuando dos escuelas del gobierno
porque iban a ser también bombardeadas
con lo cual estamos volviendo a repetir
y volviendo a ser testigos de lo que ya
pasó en el 2014 y es gravísimo porque no
se puede bombardear la
zonas de civiles y mucho menos no se
puede no van dejar las zonas donde hay
miles de personas refugiadas mire nos
quedamos sin tiempo pero le agradezco
muchísimo por este panorama que nos
entrega y deseo que puedan hacer todo lo
que está en sus manos para proteger las
vidas humanas hasta aquí este espacio
sigan con nosotros en france 24 y en
france 24 punto com
[Música]